that's a room thank you to jay
university to have this opportunity to
present our postgraduate diploma project
i will begin in display the scope of the
program architectural heritage of the
American continent was built with
natural materials that means we have a
vulnerable behavior during the
earthquakes events the Civic areas are
mostly located close to the Pacific
Ocean in the signifier for more than
eighty percent of the seismic energy of
the world is dissipated during air the
building so handsome stone buildings
good bamboo digital fibers has been used
for more than 8,000 years in this area's
also composite techniques were used to
combine these materials the main goal is
to disseminate reservation theory and
concept and civic retrofit techniques
for the Estes architectural heritage
this two-year project im sue
theoretically and practically train
interdisciplinary professional team to
preserve for World Heritage Sites
preferentially material science civil
engineering that's me materials and
structures architectural humanities and
social science that means its history
geography anthropology gallery and
philosophy anything will be the
principal disciplines more than 30 years
of research in earthquake engineering
experience on and contact with a without
the trail Harry
an e-commerce international scientific
committees there until the academic
quality of the of the project the
project also will be support with two
important facilities the earthquake
engineering a super lab with a chicken
table and dynamic tests and the
engineering and heritage laboratory that
use a non-destructive test on equipment
field practicing world heritage sites in
Peru like historical center of Lima the
old Corral shop in the winter Machu
Picchu who squandered people and
additive cities sunshine and the system
will be L system kappa gang are the
opportunities and they are planet in
this project the Prague anticipates the
cooperative exchange of graduate
students during the field season
northern hemisphere summer then I only
try to make a call for corporation
islands beginning of the degree program
in 2018 interchange of a students for
conference and field visit of a World
Heritage Sites planet for july i was for
something the first time in 2018
professor professor visits for expert
presentations are also played the
interest in cooperative program is
welcome thank you very much
you